Ferme ta gueule! Vous n’avez aucune putain d’ambition !
Mais y'a aucune communauté. Y'a aucune communauté j’te dis.
Vous arrêtez pas de me casser les couilles avecvotre communauté. Chantal !
J’en n’ai rien à foutre !
Mais non mais tu ne me laisses pas…
Tu n’as aucune idée de ce que l’on peut faire avec ça…
Tu n’as aucune idée…
Mais arrête t’es malade!
Aie. Hé oh mais ça va pas ?
Milo !
Chantal!
Chantal qu’est ce qu’il se passe?
Milo s’est barré.
Quoi?
Faut l’retrouver, j’y vais avec Magalie.
Léa?
Oui?
Il faut que tu me rendes mon corps.
Ok.
Ok Léa appelle les autres.
Chantal, Chantal, Magalie est pas assez forte.
Toi et moi on peut le chopper.
Ouais.
Georges il avait dit que…
Euh il connaît vos visages…
On aura qu’à prendre deux civils.
Ouais!
D’accord mais vous connaissez la procédure?
Ouais. Il faut des êtres insignifiants sans ambition…
Je sais
…n’exerçant aucune activité professionnelle, personnelle et/ou politique…
Je sais je sais…
…pouvant avoir un impact considéré comme bénéfique à la société.
C’est très long...
En gros il nous faut deux grosses loques biens nulles…
…qui glandent comme des gros glands.
Je sais exactement qui choisir.
Youhouuu!
Eh, sérieusement, faut vraiment qu’on arrête de sortir en semaine.
«Serge Gainsbourg aurait aujourd’hui fêté ses 87 ans.
Le chanteur français connu pour son goût prononcé
pour la cigarette et l’alcool est décédé »
Lily?
Ça te dit qu’on emménage ensemble ?
D’emmé…quoi?
On est tout le temps ensemble,
autant qu’on emménage ensemble non, c’est plus simple ?
Oui
T’es d’accord. C’est vrai?
Non t’es pas sérieuse! T’es sérieuse?
Non c’est génial!
Attends mais je vais nous trouver un nouveau canap ça va être mortel !
Et puis un lit king size!
Et je nous ai trouvé un petit robot aspirateur!
De quoi?
Un robot aspirateur! T’aimes pas faire le ménage, moi non plus,
on se trouve un petit robot, il bouge partout et c’est mortel!
« Depuis que j’ai commencé à fairece travail et en fait
ça devient un travail alors que ça a toujours été une passion avant tout.
Donc pour moi c’est assez simple.
Moi tous mestomes je les ai écrits assez rapidement, le dernier je l’ai fait en deux semaines.
Je trouve ça incroyable en fait de se...
...de s’angoisser pour ça alors que la création c’est un don avant tout
donc je ne me suis jamais posé de question,
pourquoi se poser des questionsquand on sait ce qu’on veut faire ?
Moi je n’ai pas peur du tout. Je refuse en fait »
Alors tu as fini ta BD?
Hein?
Ah ouais, ouais.
Dis moi, je me disais que peut-être demain je pourrais passer déposer...
Hein?
Je pourrais peut-être passer demain déposer des affaires !
Je suis content!
J’ai pas envie que tu emménages!
Hein? De quoi?
Hey! Salut!
Vous êtes là tous les soirs vous en fait!
Ben ça va on n’a qu’une vie!
Euh dis euh, tu nous remets deux shots de vodka.
Yer’mat
Putain Lily, il est méga tard!
Oui je sais!
Elles sont où tes clefs?
Je sais pas!
Ben tu sais pas, tu sais pas mais…
Oh c’est mon robot aspirateur, il est là!
Regarde ils l’ont livré !
Chut! Moins de bruit c’est chez moi ici!
Oh ça va! Tu vas pas nous faire un caca!
Nerveux!
Un caca nerveux Ben!
Finis tes expressions, ça veut rien dire sinon!
Non mais regarde quand même le design du truc!
Oui, oui j’ai vu Ben, ok?!
Mais tu vas pas laisser trainer ça chez moi pendant six mois, d’accord?
Ok, bon d’accord comme tu veux,
ben j’irai le remettre chez moi mais demain!
Faut quand même pas pousser mémé!
Dans les orties!
Ok, t’es prêt?
Ouais.
C’est parti!
Chut!
Chut !
Désolé! Désolé!
Merde !
Pas fait exprès.
Magalie?
Qu’est-ce que tu fais là? T’as rien à faire ici!
Je veux jouer.
Mais on n’est pas là pour jouer Magalie, on travaillenous!
Ça fait dix minutes que je te dis qu’elle nous suit.
Mais c’est vrai que tu nous fais sacrément chier putain Magalie !
Tu rentres là dedans, tu t’enfermes
et tu ne sors pas tant que je ne t’ai pas dit de sortir ok ?
Mais quelle chieuse celle-là!
Ils sont cool tes seins!
Ouais grave!
«Aujourd’hui c’est la sainte Corinne,
donc une bonne fête à toutes les… Ben les Corinne.
Fin d’édition…Et oui, la semaine prochaine il n’y aura pas d’édition.
On en a marre, on a envie de faire un break,
c’est comme ça, jevois pas mes gamins ça fait déjà douze ans,
y’a pas de raison que parce que j’ai un costard et que je suis à la télé
que j’ai pas le droit moi aussi d’avoir des vacances, merde!»
Ah et puis je me disais pour l’appartement,
peut-être qu’on pourra, je sais pas, s’arranger!
T’es qui toi?! Qu’est ce que tu fais chez moienculé ?!
Mais je suis chez moi ici!
Ben?!
Oui.
Ta gueule toi! Ben y'a un taré dans le salon!
Écoutez, vous êtes vraiment…
Tu te tais toi, tu es venu nous cambrioler c’est ça?
Non pas du tout!
Si, tu es venu nous cambrioler ! C'est pas bien, tu te casses!
Pourquoi vous…
Toute façon ça ne va pas se passer comme ça, j’appelle la copro !
Ben!
Y'avait un taré dans le salon mais je m’en suis occupé, c’est bon.
Ben?
Monsieur, laissez moi rentrer chez moi!
C’est chez moi ici!
Non non c’est chez moi j’habite ici avec ma copine alors…
Non je ne crois pas, c’est plutôt chez moi!
Lily?
Bon écoutez, la porte est fermée?
Oui.
Et bien voilà qu’est-ce qu’il vous faut de plus, barrez-vous!
Génial, super, bravo!
Ça c’est vraiment la goutte d’eau, ça!
Ben?
Oui?
Benjamin?
Benjamin Percheron?
Oui, ouvre-moi putain!
Don…Donne moi la date de notre rencontre enculé!
Je sais pas.
J’avoue, moi non plus.
Ben, t’as pas la même tête!
Lily,
t’as pas la même tête non plus.
Ok.
Téléphone.
C’est pas ma sonnerie.
Je décroche?
Coucou.
Quoi?!
Ok ok on panique pas d’accord,
on reste calme tout va bien, on essaie de se détendre.
Oh putain de merde.
C’est bon ça va bien se passer, essayez de vous détendre!
Ok.
Bon alors, en fait voilà, on avait besoin de vos corps.
On devait les ramener tôt ce matin, mais…
Bon ben il s’avère que... On a merdé quoi!
Ah ouais vous avez merdé ouais!
Désolé, on est désolés.
Mais hé hé tout va bien hein, pas de stress, ok?
Ça va on s’occupe bien de vos corps, on a toujours deux mains,
on a des bras, des jambes,
des petits seins bien ronds pas trop gros mais putain ils tiennent tout seuls quoi…
Eh oh touche pas aux seins de ma meuf toi!
Calmez-vous, calmez-vous,
vous avez été dissociésd’accord?!
Ne vous inquiétez pas tout va redevenir comme avant.
Tout ce qu’il faut c’est que vous ne bougiez pas de là ou vous êtes!
Ok.
Ok, on bouge pas.
On bouge pas.
Bon alors petit point super important, ok?!
Il y a une petite fille dans votre chambre d’amis…
Quoi?
Elle s’appelle Magalie.
Donc hé, il faut être super sympa avec elle hein?
Hein? Et vous en prenez soin jusque le temps qu’on arrive mais c’est…
Excusez-moi. Y'a…
Y'a quelqu’un derrière vous.
De quoi?
Y'a quelqu’un qui quoi? J’entends pas.
A.. Allo?
Allo?
Que… Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe, pourquoi j’ai pas terminé ma phrase, là?
Rappelle, rappelle. Rappelle-les, rappelle-les!
Elle doit avoir peur.
La pauvre.
Ok, t’es prêt?
Sacha!
Oh mon dieu!
T’es qui toi?
T’es qui ? Qu’est-ce que tu as fait de la gosse?
T’es qui ?
Magalie !
Te fous pas de ma gueule espèce de gros clodo, je vais te latter le cul!
Lily attends je crois que c’est la… Lily c’est la gosse !
Elle est où la môme?
Lily c’est elle !
Où est-ce que tu l’as mise?
Où est-ce que tu l’as mise ? Elle est où ?
Lily arrête. Lily c’est la gosse, c’est la gamine !
Elle est où la gosse? Réponds! Réponds!
Oh putain!
Quoi?
C’est la gosse, c’est elle !
Hein?
Bon, tout le monde se calme, ok?
Monsieur, est-ce que tu veux des Choco-délires?
Magalie?
Oh putain.
Tu…
Tu as quel âge ?
T’as quel âge?
J’ai cinq ans... et demi.
Oh putain…
Donc tu... Tu t’appelles Magalie?
Et t’as cinq ans.
Et demi.
Magalie.
Qu’est-ce qu’il nous arrive?
Bah…
Vous êtes dissociés.
Quoi. De quoi? Quoi?
Des dissociés!
Quoi? C’est quoi dissociés? C’est quoi, c’est grave?
Oui.
Magalie,
c’est quoi dissociés?
Qu’est-ce qu’elle fait?
Ça c’est ton âme.
Ça c’est tout ton corps.
Là on dirait c’est Sacha.
Ensuite ça a fait ça.
Et maintenant vos âmes, et bien tu peux les mettre où tu veux.
Ok. Ok.
Et comment on fait pour… Pour avoir ça?
Comme avant.
Toi je t’aime pas.
Monsieur Magalie, s’il-vous-plaît.
Je sais pas,
faut demander à Chantal.
C’est qui, c’est qui, c’est qui Chantal?
Je peux regarder la télé?
Ben non.
«Choco délire, carrément choco, complétement délire !
Mange en tous les matins putain ! J’adore ça !».
Salut.
Salut les kidous !
Hey salut les kids!
Salut les doudous!
Salut les kidous!
Alors Tiboul, sais-tu ce que m’a ramené Bobby le jardinier ce matin?
Non.
Je vais te faire deviner, un fruit qui est de couleur jaune.
Une pomme ou une banane?
Une banane!
Une banane.
Oui !
Tout de suite un épisode des ragondins de l’espace !
Ouais!
On peut parler une seconde là?
Putain, qu’est-ce que c’est que cette merde?
Qu’est-ce que c’est que cette merde?
Oh putain et qu’est-ce que c’est que ces corps de merde!
On va appeler les flics.
On leur explique on s’est fait voler nos corps, ils nous les retrouvent,
et puis tout va bien.
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait Lily, qu’est-ce qu’on fait?
Comment il fait avec ses cheveux?
Quoi?
Comment tu penses qu’il fait avec ses cheveux?
De quoi?
Non, non, mais c’est pas le moment là Lily attends il faut qu’on trouve un truc.
Attends il faut que je regarde un truc juste.
Oh mais arrête Lily qu’est-ce que tu fais, c’est dégueulasse!
Arrête ! Arrête! C’est pas ta bite.
Oh elle est plus grosse que la tienne!
Mais non mais arrête, touche pas, touche pas!
J’ai une grosse bite!
Non mais arrête c’est pas ta teub, tu touches pas à ça…
Chaton. Il faut que je teste un truc.
Quoi?
Il faut que je teste un truc.
Non, non non.
Laisse-moi tranquille!
Non, tu vas quand même pas… Non, non...
Évidemment, évidemment…
Évidemment qu’il faut que j’essaye de me branler, c’est la première fois que j’ai une bite chaton!
Non, non non…
Chaton évidemment!
T'as pas le droit de faire ça...
Tu ferais pareil à ma place! Tu ferais pareil à ma place!
Je t’aime, mais franchement.
Non, non non attends!
Tu ferais pareil!
Non mais… Non, non non non!
Magalie?
Cette Chantal, elle peut nous aider à retrouver nos corps?
Ouais.
Tu vas nous amener à Chantal, Magalie.
D’accord.
«Allez c’est parti, à l’aventure!
Ah Tiboul j’ai l’impression qu’il va nous arriver une bricole!»
Ok donc arrête-moi si je me trompe.
Ton âme est toujours dans ton corps
et aussi dans celui du livreur en bas là ?
Ouais, c’est la duplication, je t’apprendrai si tu veux.
Comme ça, ça me permet de l’observer sans me faire griller.
Bonjour Monsieur…
Qu’est-ce qu’elle est belle.
Regarde.
Je vais la faire marrer.
Attends c’est toi qui fait ça, là?
Je vais lui rajouter des...
des danseurs.
Oh qu’est-ce que vous foutez là, vous faites un flash mob, c’est ça?
Non parce que c’est la voie publique ici, c’est pas un dancing.
Moi j’ai des clients qui arrivent là, pour visiter des baraques
alors vous dégagez si vous voulez faire gangnam style c’est là-bas!
Danse avec moi.
Hop.
Et les oreilles de lapin. Voilà, allez on y va.
Viens on schwap!
Quoi?
On swap!
De quoi? Ben non. Qu’est-ce que…
On met sur la peau, comme ça…
Qu’est-ce que tu fais?
Et pouf!
Ben?
Ben c’est toi?
Ben ça va?
Ramène-toi!
Ramène-toi, remets comme avant !
On re-swap.
Allez dis pouf. Pouf, pouf!
Lily.
Ça va?
Ça va je crois.
Elle est où la petite?
Qu’est-ce que tu fais?
Qu’est-ce qu’elle fait?
Et maintenant…
Monsieur tu m’approches pas!
Casse-toi, casse-toi!
Tu te casses !
On va jouer.
Non, non!
À chat.
Ah! C’est toi le chat!
Lily?
Ah la conne!
Lily c’est toi?
Ramène-toi Magalie, c’est pas un jeu!
Qui est où là?
Comment tu fais?
Ok !
Ok, on garde la même configuration,
plus personne ne change de corps, ok ?
Magalie t’es vraiment qu’une grosse connasse!
Lily!
Si vous voulez plus jouer avec moi...
Je vais jouer dehors.
Magalie reviens!
Non mais je suis vraiment désolé, pardon, pardon.
Magalie, allez hop!
Allez file.
Encore désolé monsieur, vraiment.
Est-ce que toi aussi à chaque fois que tu changes de corps tu pètes?
Non.
Ouais, moi non plus.
Bonjour messieurs,
est-ce que vous avez entendu parler de mon associass...
Cool!
Merci beaucoup. Merci Monsieur.
Bonjour madame, est-ce que vous voulez signer...
Ouais!
Bonjour.
Merci, merci beaucoup. C’est trop cool!
Cool, trop bien!
Mais faut pas, tu peux pas faire ça Milo.
De quoi?
Je fais rien d’illégal.
Et puis je suis à plus de 25 mètres d’elle.
Mais je m’en fous de Pauline, je te parle pas de Pauline.
Tu ne peux pas manipuler les gens pour ton plaisir.
Ils ont rien demandé ces gens, toi tu leur fais faire n’importe quoi.
Attends, attends, attends.
Elle fait un discours.
C’est pour ça qu’il faut agir.
Y a trop de gens qui se bougent pas, y a trop de gens qui font rien.
Alors que,
ben on sert plus à rien si on fait pas l’effort de faire avancer ce monde.
Mais je suis pas en train de vous parler de faire un don ou de vous parler d’argent.
Non, je vous parle de solidarité, d’union.
Et d’ailleurs, le 27 juin,
notre association tous ensemble contre la mort…
Mais oui, elle a tellement raison.
Comment ça elle a raison?
Y a trop de vies qui n’ont aucun sens.
Trop de gens inutiles qui servent à rien.
Toi non plus tu sers à rien Milo.
Pas toi.
Tu vas pas t’y mettre aussi.
Elle avait raison.
Quand elle disait que tu servais à rien, elle avait raison.
C’est pas étonnant qu’elle te parle plus.
Tu la mérites pas Milo.
Ta gueule! Ta gueule!
Arrête!
Attends.
Si je supprime...
tous les gens qui servent à rien,
je sers à quelque chose.
Ah ben voilà, on va faire ça.
Je vais changer le monde.
Depuis mon canapé.
Le 27 juin, il faut qu’on soit le plus nombreux possible, pour notre association…
Attends.
T’as pas un peu faim là?
J’ai un peu faim moi.
Ouais j’avoue, je suis pas contre un petit truc à grailler.
Ouais.
On va se prendre à bouffer avant de…
de changer le monde.
Viens Magalie.
Je suis sûr que ça va bien se passer.
Chaton?
Mais vous êtes pas bien?
Bonjour Georges.
Mais Magalie où tu étais passée bon sang?!
J’étais avec eux.
Et c’est qui eux?
C’est pas Sacha et Gwen.
Vos Sacha et Gwen ils ont tiré nos corps.
Ah merde.
Hey guys, so wonderful to see you!
Ça fait du bien de vous revoir, qu’est-ce que vous foutiez?
Regarde, hashtag big beard.
Regarde, cette photo elle est trop ouf.
Attends bouge pas, bouge pas.
Terry.
Hashtag grosse barbe.
Hashtag mal au pif.
Terry. Terry!
C’est pas Sacha et c’est pas Gwen.
Ah merde.
Excusez-moi, on en parle du fait que vous veniez de nous niquer le pif là?
C’est la procédure.
Allez venez, Chantal va vous expliquer.
Génial la procédure. Vous avez pas des badges plutôt?
Ok, vous êtes prêts?
Ça va être chaud à comprendre.
Ouais allez-y on est plus à ça près.
Bien.
Donc moi je suis le boss ici, j’ai même un badge qui dit boss.
Donc je suis le boss.
Ça va jusque-là ?
Ouais.
Bien.
On est des dissociés.
On se réunit ici pour partager nos connaissances et nos pratiques.
Lui c’est Georges, à l’intérieur c’est un type de 41 ans,
on lui a volé son corps et son identité.
Par contre, n’écoutez pas ce qu’il dit, il est vraiment très con.
En face de lui, c’est Léa,
elle a gardé son corps mais méfiez-vous, surveillez vos organes génitaux
parce que sa passion dans la vie, c’est de prendre des corps d’hommes pour se masturber la bite avec.
Lui c’est Serge, on a fêté ses 87 ans hier.
Avant que son corps d’origine ne meure, il a réussi à swaper avec quelqu’un.
Avant il était chanteur mais maintenant, il a plus les mêmes cordes vocales, donc il a le seum.
Ok. Tiens Magalie, est-ce que tu peux aller chercher ça?
Non. Lily c’est pas un clébard donc…
Et lui c’est Terry. C’est juste un touriste anglais venu étudier les dissociés français.
Ouais, vous êtes marrants vous les dissociés français,
vous êtes tellement mal organisés.
Et vous à l’intérieur vous êtes quoi? Vous êtes un homme, une femme, un vieux ?
Non moi en vrai je suis une femme à l’intérieur
mais depuis que suis toute petite je me suis toujours sentie beaucoup plus homme
donc maintenant j’ai pris un corps d’homme.
Donc maintenant je suis une âme d’homme, qui est coincée dans un corps de femme
et qui actuellement est dans un corps d’homme.
Ok, donc en fait vous êtes un homme dans un corps d’homme.
Oui dit comme ça en fait c’est carrément plus simple.
Et avant j’étais noir aussi. Ça ça me manque un peu.
Ça va chaton tu suis?
Oui oui oui
Et vous c’est quoi votre nom?
Chantal.
Ah, vous êtes une femme dans un corps d’homme.
Non.
Il a juste un prénom de merde.
Ta gueule! Vraiment ta gueule!
Ok et euh...
Magalie elle vient d’où ?
Oui euh ça c’est chaud.
Il y a quelques mois, un nouveau dissocié nous a rejoint.
Milo.
Il était le plus puissant d’entre nous.
On l’admirait, il maîtrisait l’art des âmes comme personne.
Mais il était trop curieux, il voulait tout expérimenter.
Et alors que le protocole l’interdit formellement,
il a swapé avec un enfant, la petite Magalie.
Au fil de ses expériences, Milo a finit par perdre le corps de Magalie,
la condamnant ainsi à vivre toute son enfance dans un corps d’adulte.
Celui de Milo.
Nous avons alors recueillit la petite,
qui s’est vite avérée très impressionnante.
C’était la première fois que quelqu’un apprenait aussi vite.
Milo quant à lui, n’était plus digne de notre communauté.
De son coté, en secret, Milo apprenait à diviser son âme.
Lui donnant ainsi la capacité de posséder plusieurs corps en même temps.
Et le seul moyen de réveiller les gens qu’il possède est de leur coller un pain dans la gueule.
D’où la procédure.
Milo est devenu très dangereux, c’est lui qui détient vos corps.
Alors je sais que vous n’y êtes pour rien,
mais si vous voulez les récupérer vous allez devoir nous aider à l’arrêter.
Voilà.
Ok.
Et la seule personne assez puissante pour battre Milo,
c’est Magalie.
Oh y a une mouche!
Je vais l’avoir.
Elle est d’une extrême importance.
Petite mouche. Petite mouche.
Elle est notre dernier espoir.
On est tellement dans la merde.
Perso, moi je pense que même si Magalie, est niveau 98
et que Milo est niveau 100,
si on a deux âmes niveau 50, y'a moyen de l’avoir.
Non mais tais-toi Georges, y'a pas de niveaux, ça n’existe pas les niveaux.
Tu dis ça parce que t’es niveau 14.
Y'a pas de niveaux, ferme-là Georges!
Toute façon personne m’écoute ici.
Ta gueule!
Pardon. Mais y'a pas de niveaux.
C’est… c’est… y'a pas de niveaux, vraiment.
Donc, si je résume, vous vous êtes là du coup pour entrainer Magalie à battre ce Milo, c’est ça?
Voilà. C’est notre devoir.
Quand on devient dissocié on a une mission. On doit s’occuper des gens.
On est pas là pour déconner.
Putain Léa!
Rends-moi mon corps tu vas encore te branler avec t’es relou!
Chantal dis-lui d’arrêter de se branler avec ma bite.
Oh non.
Oh non, non, non, non.
Ça va faut bien que je pisse chaton.
Oh c’est tellement pratique, regarde.
Bon, qu’est-ce qu’on fait?
Je sais pas, j’en sais rien, je sais plus.
On va quand même pas passer toute notre vie dans ces corps de merde là.
Perso je commence à m’habituer,
mes seins me manquent mais ça va.
Putain regarde t’as perdu du bidon!
J’aime pas.
J’y arrive pas.
Accorde-toi un peu de temps, tu vas t’habituer…
Non j’arrive pas à pisser là, t’es juste à côté avec ta grosse teub là…
T’as vu elle est fat hein?
Ouais ouais.
Elle est gigantesque!
Y'a pas moyen, y'a pas moyen que tu restes dans ce truc,
je reste pas dans ce corps de merde là.
Je connais quelqu’un qui peut vous aider.
Y'a un dissocié comme nous qui travaille à son compte.
Il organise des swap pour que les gens malheureux échangent leur vie.
Si vous voulez un nouveau corps, il peut vous aider.
Oui, euh, sinon y a moyen de pisser tranquille ou…
Vous c’est Serge, c’est ça?
Non moi c’est Léa mais dans le corps de Serge, ouais.
Ouais, va falloir s’y habituer.
Non non, moi j’ai, moi j’ai.
Tenez, prenez sa carte.
On l’appelle le trader.
Excusez-moi, vous avez pas vu mon corps?
Léa, je t’ai vue.
On fume pas ici.
Chez nous on prend soin des corps qu’on emprunte.
C’est pas ton corps, c’est celui de tout le monde.
Pense à ceux qui vont l’emprunter demain.
Ouais.
D’autant plus qu’il est pas à toi celui-là, il est à Gwen.
On rend toujours un corps dans le même état qu’on te l’a donné.
Comme les toilettes.
Oui. Et toi quand tu prends les corps des mecs pour te branler avec
tu les rends pas vraiment dans le même état que...
Si. À peu de choses près, si.
Je les rends même plus détendus en fait.
Et toi,
quand tu swap, ça t’arrive jamais de…
justement d’un peu trop te détendre et...
je sais pas genre t’arrives dans le nouveau corps et tu…
et tu pètes.
Quoi tu pètes?
Non je pète pas.
Il pète.
Mais non, mais c’est… Non mais pas moi mais…
Mais en tout cas c’est possible si par exemple à la base j’avais prévu un pet
ben j’arrive dans un nouveau corps et je… et je…
Quand il swap il pète.
Tu me prêtes ton corps?
De quoi. Non. Pour faire tes trucs là? Non.
Ouais pour me branler. Faut pas avoir peur de dire les mots.
Tu prêtes ?
Non, non. C’est mort, c’est mort.
T’as déjà eu un corps de femme?
Non.
Bah tu devrais, si t’as pas eu une chatte au moins une fois,
tu peux pas comprendre la vie.
Chantal, pourquoi vous avez pris nos corps?
On devait suivre le protocole.
Attendez, comment ça?
Il faut des êtres insignifiants, n’exerçant aucune activité professionnelle,
sans ambition, et/ou politique pouvant avoir un impact considéré comme bénéfique pour la société.
Dans le cas où le transfert se solderait par un échec,
la perte de leur âme ou de leur enveloppe corporelle serait considérée comme négligeable.
Négligeable?
Non, non mais on a pu se tromper!
Je suis sûr que tu as un super boulot, une passion,
t’as un mec, t’es amoureuse, tout ça quoi.
Ouais. Ouais.
Et bien si tu veux j’ai toujours détesté mon corps d’avant.
Donc j’avais l’habitude d’échanger régulièrement avec un gars, on faisait ça comme ça, régulièrement.
À l’amiable tu vois.
Mais bon voilà, le corps a claqué quand c’était lui dedans donc si tu veux je me suis dit...
J'me suis dit pas de bol quoi tu vois.
Du coup je me retrouve dans ce corps à la con là.
Une gueule de cul, je sais pas si tu as vu là, excuse-moi mais…
Pour chan…
Pour chanter des chansons si tu veux c’est même pas possible d’aligner des mélodies correctement.
Regarde celle-là elle est géniale.
Excellent. Je vais mettre sur hashtag celle-là, hashtag...
bougon
et hashtag…
Eh oh !
Hashtagueule, hashtagueule, hashtagueule.
Hey monsieur, non mais qu’est-ce que c’est que ce chantier ?
Non mais t’es taré toi! Oh !
Monsieur, on ne pique le sandwich…
Oh putain. Oh putain.
Viens viens viens viens.
C’est un peu de la merde comme entrainement, non?
Ça a l’air simple comme ça mais c’est Magalie qui se lance une balle à elle-même,
elle swap de corps en corps.
Sans contact?
Ouais.
On appelle ça le swap wifi.
On appelle pas ça du tout le swap wifi.
Allez, maintenant Magalie, possède-moi.
J’ai pas envie!
Allez ça va aller, t’inquiète pas. Vas-y.
Plus fort.
Je suis fatiguée.
Quelle chieuse.
T’inquiète pas.
On recommence une dernière fois et après on va goûter, d’accord ?
C’est beau l’art des âmes, quand même.
Du coup est-ce que deux âmes peuvent être dans le même corps?
Fusionner? Non.
Une âme prend forcement le pas sur l’autre et finit par la détruire.
Et est-ce que ça marche avec les animaux?
Comment ça?
Est-ce que si je…
Chaton?
Ben?
Je crois que tu parles à une mouche.
Oh la mouche.
Je vais l’avoir!
Non Magalie! Non surtout pas!
Ok Ben, il faut que tu re-swap dans ton corps d’origine maintenant.
Ça va Ben, c’était comment?
C’était complètement dingue!
Oh putain c'était dingue, vous étiez géants!
Magalie, tu as essayé de me tuer ?
C’était trop marrant!
Oh putain, c’est dingue!
Montrez-moi d’autres trucs, c’était ouf !
Magalie, Lily et moi on va rentrer.
Je peux venir avec vous?
Non Chantal a dit que tu devais rester là.
J’aime pas ici y a tout le temps du bruit et chez vous c’est mieux.
Désolé Magalie, je…
Vous allez où?
On rentre.
Non, Magalie tu restes ici.
Je veux rentrer chez eux, ils ont un lit, eux!
Mais on s’en fout Magalie tu as de l’entrainement putain.
Mais vous allez arrêter de forcer les gens vous, bordel!
Ok. Vous ne comprenez pas, Magalie est très importante, elle est puissante, elle doit juste…
Mais arrêtez de parler d’elle comme si c’était une arme, c’est une enfant de cinq ans vous voyez pas?
Elle a énormément de barbe mais c’est une enfant de cinq ans quand même.
Allez, on rentre Magalie.
Lève ta tête.
C’est pour moi?
C’est qui, c’est tes parents?
Ça c’est toi
ça c’est Ben
et ça c’est moi!
C’est joli en tout cas.
Tu veux aller regarder la télé?
Oh oui ! Salut les kidous!
« Bonjour à tous !
Bonjour!
Bienvenue dans cuisiner c’est sympa.
Tu nous entends le blizzard, tu nous entends? Si tu nous entends va te faire…
enculer.
Alors Chris, qu’est-ce que ça fait d’être une grosse merde? Hein?
Hashtag merde. Hashtag merde. Hashtag grosse merde.
Hashtag gros prout de merde.
Le Président aurait volon… Oh...
Tiboul, quels sont les chiffres existants?
Le un ?
Oui!
Le deux ?
Le trois?
Oui !
Quatre!
Le quatre?
Oui !
Le cinq?
Le six?
Ah, nan! »
Qu’est-ce que vous faites chez moi?
On vient t’arrêter Milo.
Il faut que tu t’arrêtes maintenant…
Faut surtout que vous partiez de chez moi en fait.
J’ai dit que je voulais plus rien avoir à faire avec vous.
Mec fais pas le con, ils ont rien demandé.
Ils ont trouvé où j’habitais, il faut que je les possède.
Non sérieux, fais pas ça.
Oui oui, votre ami a raison, c’est vrai.
Mon ami? Qui?
Lui? C’est pas mon ami.
Lui c’est le…
le… attends t’étais qui déjà avant?
J’étais qui déjà avant moi?
J’étais dans l’appart, ça c’est sûr.
Attends, je check.
T’étais qui?
Non, laissez-moi!
T’étais qui avant?
Faites pas votre truc, non! Non !
Calme-toi, tu étais qui avant que je te possède ?
Tu étais qui?
Mais je suis, je suis votre voisin. Je voulais juste un peu d’huile d’olive…
C’est ça.
Le voisin,
du dessus.
On les récupère?
Ben oui ben du coup on va pas les laisser comme ça, oui.
Ça va?
Fais attention ça nous affaiblit.
Bon allez, à demain, bonne nuit.
Dodo.
Lily ?
Oui?
Tu me racontes une histoire?
On a pas de livre pour enfant ici, je suis désolée.
Ok, alors... Le dictionnaire.
Sois pas conne.
Non y'a du cul dans cette BD, ouais y'a trop de cul.
Chapitre 1. Allumage.
Branchez le câble d’alimentation de la base de chargement sur une prise domestique 220 Volts.
Commencez par initialiser l’appareil en appuyant longtemps sur le bouton d’allumage
jusqu’à que la diode soit verte.
Phase de repérage.
L’aspirateur, le… Nono, le robot,
Nono l’aspiro, doit établir une carte de l’espace à nettoyer.
Phase de nettoyage…
Ben?
Je te plais?
Ben tu as une belle robe.
T’aimes bien avoir des seins?
Ouais.
C’est ouf.
Merde.
Tu sais...
Que t’aies une bite ou pas, moi je m’en fous.
On est d’accord qu’il faut qu’on essaye de baiser dans cette config?
Ouais. On est d’accord.
Vous avez tellement de la chance!
Tu crois qu’on peut swaper euh…
Pendant?
Ouais.
Tout le long?
Oui ! oui !
Euh je vois ça avec ta sœur et on part en week-end à Porquerolles.
Sinon on part de La Ciotat et ensuite on se pose deux ou trois jours quoi.
Allez vas-y Magalie.
Plus fort.
Allez plus fort!
Plus fort, c’est bien. Encore!
C’est pas grave, c’est pas grave, c’est pas grave,
vas-y recommence,
allez je crois en toi!
Allez, c’est bien!
Ok. Lily, Ben, vous êtes tous les deux d’accord pour swaper?
Oui.
Ok. Concentrez-vous.
Et…
C’est parti!
Nickel.
Plus fort ! Plus fort!
Allez, lâche pas Magalie!
Accroche-toi !
Je suis dans les deux en même temps!
Bravo Magalie, tu m’as possédé!
Bravo c’est bien je suis fier de toi !
C’est bien !
C’est moi qui ai fait.
Ben rends-moi mon corps.
Deux secondes.
Non tu fumes pas dans mon corps Ben.
Ça va deux secondes!
Non c’est mon corps c’est pas le tien!
Non mais Lily c’est pas ton corps.
Ben arrête de faire le gamin là.
Ça va je gère Lily, tu peux me faire confiance un peu.
Putain.
Ben!
Ben tu fais chier là. Putain mais t’es lourd.
Ils sont forts les nouveaux quand même.
Quel niveau?
Je dirai autour de 40 chacun.
J’en ai marre ! J’en ai marre ! j’en peux plus !
De quoi tu en as marre de quoi?
J’en ai marre de toi!
Merci c’est cool!
De rien!
Léa,  excuse-moi,
est-ce que tu as encore la carte du mec qui échange les vies?
Quoi?
Tu veux changer de vie?
Je sais pas, mais…
Et tu comptes en parler à Ben?
Non, non lui dis rien s’il-te-plait.
Donc tu comptes te casser comme ça sans rien dire à personne
comme une grosse lâche quoi.
Quoi?
Rends-moi mon corps s’il-te-plait.
Déjà? Ok.
Ben?
Non non non non.
C’est bon, ça va lâche-moi. C’est bon j’ai compris.
Non tu comprends pas laisse-moi t’expliquer. Laisse-moi t’expliquer.
Arrête.
Lily.
Barre toi. Vas-y fais-le.
Vas-y pars, vas-y va-t’en, on s’en fout de toute façon tu fais toujours ça Lily.
À chaque fois c’est comme ça, dès qu’il y a un problème tu gères pas la situation
et tu pars, tu fais rien.
C’est plus simple de rien faire, c’est vrai c’est plus simple.
C’est vrai non, c’est pas vrai?
Ta BD, ta BD tu l’as terminée,Lily?
Non.
Non? Pourquoi tu l’as pas terminé, c’est bizarre.
Pourquoi parce que tu as peur Lily, tu as toujours peur.
On emménage pas ensemble non plus, c’est bizarre, pourquoi on emménage pas ensemble?
Lily.
On sert enfin à quelque chose là, j’ai l’impression que, je sais pas...
Qu’on peut aider ces gens et faire un truc bien pour une fois mais…
Toi tu veux tout casser mais vas-y casse tout.
Je m’en fous, c’est vraiment la cerise.
Sur le gâteau.
Ok tout le monde.
On va aller attaquer cet enfoiré de Milo.
Je suis pas prête.
Ça va bien se passer ma chérie, t’inquiète pas.
Quand j’étais petit,
je voulais être pilote,
pilote de chasse.
Et vous savez ce qu’il ne faut surtout pas être pour devenir pilote de chasse?
Nain.
Être nain.
Est-ce que vous allez vous retourner à un moment?
Ah oui.
Pardon.
Et puis un jour on m’a dissocié.
J’ai transcendé mes émotions,
mes souvenirs, mon âme toute entière dans un autre corps.
Un corps plus grand,
plus vif, plus vigoureux, plus beau!
Un corps que j’ai usé aussi, que j’ai souillé.
Et puis après j’ai eu d’autres rêves,
j’ai vécu dans d’autres corps, j’ai eu d’autres vies,
j’ai eu toutes les couleurs, tous les âges.
Vous savez, la vie ne nous accorde jamais le droit de réaliser nos rêves.
C’est pour ça que moi j’aime bien l’idée de réaliser ceux des autres,
donner l’alternative.
J’organise des échanges, des rencontres,
j’offre le bonheur.
Lily…
C’est Lily, hein?
Oui.
Est-ce que vous voulez changer de vie?
Donc si j’ai bien compris, Milo vit dans le douzième arrondissement.
Tiens?
Qu’est-ce que c’est?
Je vais voir.
Elle est où Lily?
Nous avons un catalogue très complet.
Choisissez un profil
et cette vie est à vous.
Vous… Vous avez cette personne?
Oui!
Oui c’est une personne qui n’est pas très satisfaite de son existence.
Vous voulez cette vie?
Oui.
Bien.
Vous signez ici en bas,
je vous laisse le temps de lire.
Attendez, vous êtes qui là, qu’est-ce que vous faites là?
Attendez qu’est-ce que vous faites?
Non non non !
J’en connais qui vont être contents.
Ils sont clean au moins?
Mais bien sûr qu’ils sont cleanputain! Georges!
J’imagine que tu avais hâte de récupérer ton corps?
Désolé.
Vous êtes Milo, c’est ça?
J’ai tous les dissociés,
il ne me reste plus que toi.
Je suis en ce moment même dans la boite de nuit.
Je cours après ton mec et la petite.
Oh, je me rapproche,
ça y est, je les ai eus!
J’espère que t’as prévu autre chose qu’un sac à main pour me…
Et voilà !
C’est chez toi.
Magalie et l’autre courent vite, j’ai du mal à les rattraper.
Y a pas d’issue, ils ne peuvent pas s’enfuir.
Je les ai perdus.
Bon, en tout cas tu peux t’installer ici maintenant, tu seras en sécurité.
Moi j’ai honoré ma partie du contrat, à toi d’honorer la tienne.
Chantal,
tu pensais vraiment que j’allais t’apprendre la possession?
Je me suis fixé une mission et je n’ai pas de temps à perdre à enseigner mon art.
Encore moins à un dissocié de niveau 2.
Ben?
Ok, ok, ok.
Ça va?
Ouais ça va.
Magalie?
Elle est là.
Ok.
Donc, ce que je te disais. Quand on arrive à Porquerolles,
il faut qu’on prenne un bateau pour aller dans les îles et du coup on achète des crustacés…
Excusez-moi!
Vous avez l’heure?
Oui.
Il est 15h...
Je t’aime.
Magalie! Magalie!
Comment on éteint, Ben?
Je sais pas. Je sais pas
C’est toi qui sais, c’est toi qui l’as acheté, je ne sais pas comment on l’éteint celui-là.
Ça aussi j’aurais pas dû l’acheter?
Mais n…
Mais non mais…
Le bouton marche plus…
Je suis désolé Ben.
Je sais, je sais que j’ai tout fait rater.
Je voulais…
On a tout raté.
Je suis prête.
Ok.
Donc quand on sera dans la rue, le but du jeu c’est de ne pas se faire toucher, d’accord?
On joue à chat?
Voilà, c’est ça.
Sauf que nous on est les souris et les chats, c’est tous les autres, d’accord?
Puis si jamais je me fais toucher tu me mets une grosse…?
Patate!
Oui! C’est bien ma chérie.
Pour pas se faire toucher, va falloir sortir couvert.
Ok c’est bon, vous êtes prêts?
Je transpire déjà comme un porc.
Ok, ok, ok, vite!
Vite allez!
Allez vite, vite!
Vite vite vite!
Vite putain!
Allez grouille, grouille!
Merde, merde, merde, merde, merde, merde.
Ok quand les portes s’ouvrent, je fonce dans le tas et vous vous passez, d’accord?
Ok, on se sort les doigts.
Du cul, du cul.
On se sort les doigts du cul.
Pendant quelques secondes j’avais l’impression d’être dans le corps de quelqu’un d’autre,
c’était complètement…
Là, regarde-là!
Toi t’es dans moi et moi je suis dans toi, là !
Yannick…
Vas-y fonce, fonce!
Oh putain de merde.
Et merde.
Ok.
Ok ça va, ça va Terry.
Ok un peu de glaçons.
Voilà, presse-ça fort, voilà.
Ça va aller ? Ça va ?
Ouais ça va…
Ok.
Magalie!
Léa!
Terry…
Lily !
Merci.
Non non mais c’est bon je suis plus possédé là.
Je sais.
Merci Ben.
Thanks.
Attends, attends doucement, doucement.
Allez t’en as toujours eu envie !
Qu… Quoi?
Mais… je sais que tu me rejetais et que tu as choisi ce connard là,
mais dans le fond c’est toujours moi que tu as voulu, je le sais allez!
Mais de quoi tu parles?
Ah putain mais c’est moi!
Milo?
Ouais.
J’ai beaucoup changé Pauline.
Je vais sauver le monde,
je vais nous débarrasser  de tous ceux qui nous empêchent d’avancer là.
Je l’ai enfin trouvé ma place.
T’es prête?
Oui!
Allez vas-y on s’occupe d’eux!
Tu préfères te taper toi-même ou me taper moi?
Euh…
Me taper moi.
Oh putain.
Ça coûte combien de se faire refaire le nez?
Je sais pas, c’est très très cher!
Je l’ai eu!
Je l’ai eu c’est bon!
Non, c’est pas bon! C’est pas bon!
On échange?
Ok.
Olive! Je voulais juste un peu d’huile d’olive!
Mais putain t’es qui toi?
Tiens, prends ça!
Merci.
Putain, j’aime pas trop l’idée de taper une meuf…
Mais en plus là c’est toi!
Dis-toi que je suis un homme, possédé par un autre homme.
Ne m’embrouille pas, je frappe où, au visage?
Non!
Évite de me péter les dents s’il-te-plait!
Sur le ventre?
Euh ouais. Non!
Enfin évite de taper les ovaires, je veux pas de souci si on a des enfants!
Quoi?
Tu parles d’avoir des gosses et tu veux même pas d’un putain de robot aspirateur!
Mais ça va!
Oh putain mais j’en chie Lily, donne-moi ton point faible!
La clavicule, je me suis cassé la clavicule quand j’étais petite!
Bien joué.
Merci.
J’ai quand même un pur boule, hein?
Ouais, je te l’ai toujours dit!
Ouais.
J’y vais.
Ben!
Magalie, Magalie!
Je sais que tu m’entends,
tu peux lutter contre lui.
Magalie, c’est moi.
C’est Lily,
c’est moi Magalie, tu m’entends?
Oui.
Oui c’est bien Milo. C’est…
C’est bien si tu veux changer le monde, c’est bien.
Je savais que ça te ferait plaisir.
Si je peux pas t’avoir en te faisant plaisir…
Il faut qu’on y retourne!
Il faut qu’on y retourne.
Il faut qu’on aille la sauver.
Non, non.
C’est trop tard.
Non, non, non.
On la laisse pas.
On la laisse pas, on y retourne.
Allez.
C’est fini Lily, c’est fini.
À deux,
à deux dans le même corps on sera plus forts. Allez on y retourne!
Allez!
Non c’est pas possible.
Si.
Non, on y arrivera pas.
Si Ben, j’ai confiance en nous.
J’ai confiance en nous.
Oui.
Allez on se motive chaton, et on y va.
Ben?
Ouais?
Ça va chaton?
Nickel!
Lily?
Oui?
On est tout le monde en même temps?
Ouais je crois.
Lilly,
si tu veux rester dans un de ces corps je comprendrai.
Je veux pas être un obstacle pour toi.
Non mais, ils ont rien demandé ces gens.
Je veux rester avec toi Ben.
Et Ben?
Oui?
Moi aussi quand je swap je pète.
J’en étais sûr!
Allez viens,
on rentre chez nous.
Ok, pourquoi je suis le seul en slip?
Magalie…
Magalie!
Mag…
Mag, ca va?
Magalie on a gagné!
Mag?
Mag? Oh Mag allez!
Ça va on est là.
Magalie?
Ben, pourquoi elle se réveille pas?
Lily, Lily.
Oh non, non, non, non.
T'es plus le boss de qui que ce soit.
Euh… Guys?
Oh putain de merde, putain de merde, choppez-la!
Choppez-la putain!
Je l’ai eue!
Magalie!
Qu’est qu’il y a?
Y’a rien, y a rien du tout!
Il est où Milo?
Il est…
Il est là, il est juste là!
Il va bien,
presque.
Oh put... euh…
hum…
Jean-Jacques? On a fait la météo du... des fourmis?
Ou c’est les dauphins là?
Oh j’en peux plusde la météo des fourmis là.
Jean-Jacques?
Lily?
Quoi?
Quand on avait dit qu’on partagerait la grossesse,
on avait pas dit que je me taperais toutes les nausées!
Mais t’inquiète je vais prendre le prochain vomi mon petit chaton.
Ouais non parce que je me demande vraiment comment on va s’organiser pour l’accouchement...
Et te connaissant, y a moyen que tu me laisses faire tout le sale boulot
et que tu swapes au dernier moment juste pour avoir le bébé sur le ventre!
Mais non, on se partagera l’accouchement équi…tablement mon chéri je te le promets.
Je te rappelle que j’ai besoin de savoir ce qui fait le plus mal entre un accouchement
et un coup de pied dans les couilles.
Tu finiras plus tard, faut qu’on y aille.
Chantal, deux virgin mojito s’il te plait.
Ça marche boss.
Ok non t’inquiète pas,
t’inquiète pas c’est normal, c’est normal.
Donc comme d’habitude ma vessie est un peu capricieuse donc je peux pisser à tout moment.
D’accord? Et si il donne des coups de pieds c’est normal.
Merci Sacha.
Ça marche.
Hey Ben, ça va?
Ça va!
T’es bien comme ça aussi!
Merci!
Hey, ça va la mouche?
Cela… va… bien…
Oui, c’est bien Mouchi!
On doit s’occuper d’un nouveau taré.
Le collectionneur.
Un type en Angleterre qui a appris à extraire l’âme d’un corps
et qui s’amuse à stocker les corps dans sa cave.
Il collectionne les corps vides le gars!
Bon je peux vous laisser faire?
Ouais!
J’ai rendez-vous.
Bien, bonjour à tous,
alors aujourd’hui on accueille des petits nouveaux.
Vous inquiétez pas on va vous expliquer ce qu’il vous arrive.
Ouais.
De toute façon vous allez vite comprendre, on va s’échauffer.
Magalie?
On va jouer à chat!
Hé oh mais ça va pas?
Milo!
Aie !
Fuck ça fait super mal ! T’es c...
Fuck, that really hurts !
Arrête tout de suite!
Ok ! Ok !
Tu te calmes! Tu te calmes!
Allez! On l’a, on l’a…
C’est bon, Milo est devenu fou mais c’est bon on l’a neutralisé.
Ok c’est bon aucun problème.
L’histoire s’arrête ici, vraiment.
Ça n’a aucune incidence sur la suite.
Ok.
Allez, on va goûter?
Ouais, on va goûter.
Hé ben c’était chaud!
T’imagines si il s’était barré?
Il aurait pu se passer un maximum de trucs quoi.
Alors que là non, vraiment rien quoi.
Fin.